what does a guy look like that you would
want
to marry and have his children like what
would he have to
be he would have to well I'm I'm a
Christian and I'm very much in my faith
so that would religion like be the same
religion as me that's that's huge um and
then he would go to church regularly
yeah yeah okay yeah um he would have to
um be very ious just because I think
that men that are ambitious just have
the best mentality and just like the
overall structure in their life it's not
even a financial thing but yes of course
that matters I think marriage is a
business agreement so obviously he needs
to know how to handle the money um and I
want to be able to to trust him in that
um I think that if he said a budget
would you follow it like if he said you
know you've got x amount of dollars to
work with every every
month and it may not be something that
you're happy with but he's Christian and
he's ambitious but he sets you a budget
that might be less than what you're
happy with working with would you be
okay with that yeah
absolutely yeah absolutely like I I
that's not even something that I'm
really thinking about I've I grew up
very poor I can make a budget work I've
been making a budget work my whole life
okay um have you dated many Christian
guys no that is a big issue that I'm
having I will start to talk to somebody
and in my very naive brain sometimes
I'll think like oh like maybe like he'll
see I'm so Jesus likee and he'll wanna
like maybe be more open to it and it
never works and just so just never goes
anywhere oh okay so you're hoping to
convert them to your yeah I'm over that
I used to do that but I it doesn't work
so now I need to I would need to find
someone that's in in my faith and I'm
open to dating someone that is um
Catholic Orthodox just believes in in
Christ why is that important like why do
they have to believe in Christ like what
about an
atheist um I
think I per it's my opinion that if
someone's an atheist it's a little
ridiculous to even get married because
marriage is a Biblical thing and so um
whenever you meet someone that's in the
same Faith as you and they they read the
Bible it's like you get a you have an
understanding
of what your roles are each in each
marriage I don't know if you've ever
like you're probably not actually
marriage isn't really a Biblical thing
there's a book by Stephanie K called
marriage a history and she goes through
Diaries and court records over hundreds
of years to sort of establish um you
know why people got married and it was
about the acquisition of in-laws right
you know so if you went back a thousand
years and you needed Medical Care law
enforcement um somebody that had certain
skills it would be ideal to merge your
family of seven or eight with his family
of nine or 10 or something like that
because there would be skills in his
family set with you know that should be
complimentary to your sort of thing
right um like my last name's Cooper you
go back to the old medieval days and
Coopers were Barrel makers right and
there was the Smiths and there was you
know the other people that had all the
other skills so it wasn't
about anything in the Bible it was about
basically strengthening your network so
you could solve
problems oh that's interesting I didn't
know that thank you for sharing with me
but for me and my and but but marriage
is also in the Bible so for me as a as a
Christian I I choose I think marriage is
a sacred thing for
between to Rel have you ever tried like
um uh I don't know what's the Christian
when Christian mingler or something like
that you ever tried any of those dating
sites no no no interest honestly that's
interesting why not because I I have
well people like within my church I have
friends within my church and it's kind
of like a joke to everybody in the
church why it's kind because it's a lot
of um catfishes it's a lot of fake
accounts it's a lot of like um like
scammers um also it's it's not not
really like everyone just kind of makes
a joke out of it like it's not really
something that that we do I just don't
think I could see myself on it yeah
because I mean there's so many guys out
there that are all about you know faith
and religion and Christianity and sort
of thing you see them all over social
media all the time especially on um
Twitter X um like they'll have back and
forths into perpetuity about the about
some of the most random things and
they're always talking about finding you
know a traditional conservative sort of
girl and they talk about the dating site
sort of thing so I always thought that
Christian Mingle was like something that
these guys would legitimately use to try
to find a a guy like
Rachel well okay so in my Bible study
which is just women in their 20s to 30s
um a lot of them are are single still
but it's either you're you're married or
you're you're single there's no like
boyfriends really and um the girls in
there it's like none of them none of
them are on dating sites and they've
never like that's not something that
whenever they talk about meeting
somebody yeah they like hope that they
meet somebody at a churching event or
like a church event or somewhere within
the church
that's that's like their their goal it's
never um online
really they don't spend much time online
at all actually okay Brandy you were
nodding your head when we were talking
about uh faith and religion is that
something that's important to you too
yeah yes absolutely can you explain why
is it for the same reasons or I would
say so yeah it like you want to you want
to you know surround yourself around God
like and he should be number one always
and I I feel like if you build a
relationship where he's the center of it
it
is I mean that's everything that would
be literally everything why is but how
does that manifest itself in reality
like what do you mean by you put God
first God comes first I mean how does
that how does that manifest itself in
actionable items I mean like part of the
reason I think that Christianity is sort
of kind kind of gotten this Monopoly on
marriage is that I don't know what the
statistics actually are I would venture
to Guess that Christian households or
Christian marriages tend to have um less
chance of divorce or I know that at
least in Catholicism I think the penalty
is excommunication you really can't get
divorced it's sort of forbidden so in
these cases it's it's very much almost a
kind of a covering your ass thing but
I'm curious because I hear a lot of
these sort of allegorical statements
when when I when I come across these
subjects about you know it's God family
wife or kids or whatever whatever the
order is but like how does that how like
what does that mean if two people are
saying okay well God is at the center
what does that really mean and in sort
of
layman's terms well I mean it's it's all
about believing in in a higher power
right so it's it's not about like
Christianity anything like that it's
it's you
know believing in in him and having that
faith that you know he will make
everything work you know like I said
it's he he's he chooses our path so you
just have to trust him to follow you
know and follow it so I mean if you if
you if you have a relationship where you
know you both have that strong faith
then it that's that sort of works
everything out in itself because you
always know that if you disagree in
something you know
that that's what you come back to I
guess is it's really hard to explain it
I guess because it it's it's really an
opinion in in everybody's sense but
that's just the way I feel you
know I don't know if that really
answered your question yeah I don't
think so answer did did that answer your
question
off Rachel you want to try you want to
give maybe
okay um the way I see it is um it's more
like my faith is a big part of my life
just like my family is going to be a big
a big part of my life and ideally I
would want my husband to lead in my
family so if my faith is a big deal to
me I'd also want my husband to lead in
in my faith and biblically it speaks
about that it speaks about the husband
leading the household the husband
leading the faith and so that aligns
with My Views because I'm a Christian so
that's why I feel like that implements
things and whenever what she was saying
like issues like in the relationship and
and how are you you go to to God to help
you solve those things it's it's just
more of like people who are believers
they don't go to typically they don't go
to Vices to whenever things go bad they
go to God and if you can do that as a
couple like you could resolve a lot of
your issues that way I want to grab the
super chat in a second but I want to
phrase it slightly differently so let's
say you find a guy who agrees with
absolutely all of that um guy leading
taking
responsibility taking ownership for his
life being accountable for everything
that he does like that's that's pretty
much everything that you've covered
there
right but then he says says to himself
and to you and to your family but I
don't think there's anything out there
that's more powerful than me I am not
going to bend the knee to anything
because I am the one that is in the
driver's seat and I'm going to lead this
and I'm going to take responsibility for
her for my kids for everybody that I've
that I've drawn a perimeter around that
I care about and Lead is that something
that you would be okay with or do they
have to be
Christian
um because I mean all of those traits
that you've described are essentially
part of your faith but he's just saying
I don't think there's a higher power
than anything beyond me that I take full
responsibility and accountability for
everything um I well you can still take
accountability for everything and still
be a believer so I don't really if a not
a believer in God he's a believer in
himself well then I just couldn't do
that because for what I believe in and
is that there is a higher power and it's
not a this Earth so I can't as much as I
would let my husband lead my life and my
family like it would it would be my
husband's led by God and I'm led by my
husband that that's the order to me
personally got it okay um so Rizo said
over here I'm not learned on most
religions but wasn't marriage invented
for resources and combining and strength
think fames like rich said yeah it's
it's the book is called marriage a
history Stephanie C is the author um
basically some you know the tldr version
is um people marry for the acquisition
of in-laws not because of religion or
for any other uh reasons that have been
outlined it's
like there's often a difference between
what people say and what they do and I
think that it's reasonable to watch
behaviors over what people say so if
behaviors indicate that choices were
made for the acquisition of in-laws
then everything that's reasoned around
that with the data that they collect um
you know makes a lot of sense but there
there's there's always
been like in all scripture and all
religions throughout history there's
there's always some combination of roles
with men and women and usually some form
of Union which is defined as a marriage
or some or some degree of that so that's
they sort of like co-mingled sort of
thing but the the choices behind getting
married are always about the acquisition
of in in-laws not for love not for
children not for you know Faith or
religion or God or any of those things I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out